[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis stressé j'ai pas dormi de la
nuit
c'est la dernière plongée de ma saison
et je sens qu'elle va être déterminante
pour la suite
on est début octobre je suis aux
championnats du monde en turquie
mes pensées fusent dans tous les sens
mon coeur bat à cent à l'heure et je me
demande bien ce que je fais ici
allongée sur le dos flottant à la
surface de l'eau je cherche à fuir cette
tension qui me paralyse alors mes
pensées et mon regard plonge dans le
ciel je m'évade loin loin de toute cette
agitation
je me remémore toutes les personnes qui
m'inspire et me donne envie de rêver le
brouhaha autour de moi n'est plus qu'un
bruit sourd je me laisse bercer par des
vagues
la seule chose que j'entends
distinctement c'est le compte à rebours
il me rappelle que c'est maintenant
alors si vous le voulez bien je vous
propose de plonger avec moi vous avez du
souffle des vous entendez des comptes
je vous invite à prendre une grande
inspiration et en plongeant semble vous
êtes prêts alors c'est parti
d'un coup je bascule dans le silence ça
y est je suis seul seul avec moi-même
mon corps est en mode automatique
il enchaîne les gestes techniques à la
seconde près
tel un métronome à 30 mètres la pression
est telle que je suis aussi denses et
lourdes qu'une pierre qui coule alors je
me laisse partir comme attirés par les
abysses
j'ai les yeux entrouverts le filin qui
défilent devant moi me penot tease le
froid main wailly la vitesse car est-ce
qu'on visage je coule à un mètre seconde
il fait de plus en plus sombres la
pression s'abat sur ma cage thoracique à
ces profondeurs je suis neuf bars de
pression
l'équivalent d'un poids lourd de 15
tonnes qui m'écrase c'est tellement
violent que je ne ressens rien je suis
comme en dehors de mon corps et je me
sent étrangement bien toute mon
attention est maintenant braqués sur mes
oreilles je cherche désespérément l'air
qui lui aussi s'est fait comprimé par la
pression l'enjeu de taille sans air pour
équilibrer mes oreilles et m'a plongée
s'arrête net
les maîtres d'eschyle je sens que mon
objectif sera proche
c'est magique je me sens libre ça y est
le fonds se rapproche
je saisis le tag qui va me servir de
témoin à ce moment précis
j'ai une pensée pour la surface le
drones sous-marins retransmet
instantanément je suis en direct et ça
me donne une force incroyable
ces images inédites vont révolutionner
notre sport en permettant de médiatiser
mais retour à la réalité
82 m à remonter à la seule force de mes
jambes
c'est la hauteur d'un immeuble de 35
étages l'effort est intense je dois
m'arracher du fonds ça fait plus de deux
minutes trente que je respire plus je
dois rester concentré
commence alors une longue bataille entre
mon corps et mon esprit j'ai le dr fran
qui se contracte de plus en plus
violemment
mes jambes se font de plus en plus
lourdes alors ma petite voix intérieure
me rassure en me disant que je n'ai
jamais fait de syncope et ça mon corps
s'en souvient très bien alors mon corps
s'apaise et se calme et me laisse
profiter de la remontée vers 30 mètres
les apps nice de sécurité mais ange
gardien me rejoignent ils sont à l'affût
du moindre signe de faiblesse pour me
secourir en cas de défaillance
non
la première inspiration est un
électrochoc
c'est comme si je me réveillais en
sursaut d'un rêve si on n'est pas bien
préparés ou si on accourt d'air la
première inspiration peut être fatale et
nous conduire à la syncope
tel un fusible qui fait tout chanter le
signe ok valide mon intégrité physique
le tag que j'ai glissé dans ma cagoule
témoigne que je suis allé à la
profondeur annoncé ces deux éléments
sont indispensables pour valider ma
performance
cartons blancs record de france 82 m 3
minutes 20
daphné je me classe 4e mondial
[Applaudissements]
improbable pour une jeune auvergnat
tenue au milieu des volcans de rêver de
profondeur j'ai eu le coup de foudre
pour l'apnée il ya dix ans dans les
bassins chlorés de clermont ferrand j'ai
plongé pour la première fois dans les
lacs d'eau verne
puis mon instinct m'a m'a guidé jusqu'à
nice avec le souhaite plonger plus
régulièrement en 2013 mais mon métier de
chirurgien dentiste m'a écarté de ma
passion mais impossible pour moi de me
résigner
j'ai renoué en septembre dernier j'ai
battu le record de france en monopalme
ma discipline de prédilection
je suis descendu à 88 mètres de
profondeur aux bahamas en juillet
dernier puis à 10 jours ce record de
france en vie palme une nouvelle
discipline pour moi plus longue et plus
intense physiquement de très bonne
augure pour la suite
mon rêve est la première française à
franchir la barre mythique des 100 m
alors je voudrais vous faire un aveu
j'ai pas confiance en moi et plus loin
mais sous l'eau j'ai totalement
confiance en moi je suis forte et
invincible alors j'espère que vous aussi
est un endroit où vous sentez invincible
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]